[Music]
it's about love and friendship
this is your second film with director
whit stillman I love his work this is a
very funny movie congratulations in the
first film it's interesting that you did
with him you didn't it was not required
for this movie where a British accent
was necessary but in the first film that
you did with him you it was last days of
disco you needed an American accent it
did and it was the first time I'd ever
had to do whenever is it hard to do an
American accent I know Americans butcher
an English accent I know we do I've seen
you do it
Oh Oh two sausages if you will he's
holding holding an invisible chimney
brush yeah sweet dough chimney or will
or will this is why I'm banned from ever
performing outside of the studio in any
capacity but is it difficult because I
remember that movie you had a view had a
very good American it's a very specific
very it was whit Saxon basically and I
had only spent maybe four days in
American two of them were in Disneyland
and it was absolutely no use tour and I
was only nine so I wasn't paying
attention so yeah so I turned up there
and it was a very low-budget movie and
they didn't have a voice coach on every
day and so I sort of thought okay how am
I gonna pull this off so I I was I
didn't know anyone in New York I sat in
the hotel room sort of semi head
watching a bit of television there
mainly on television at that time it
seemed like there was a lot of
commercials for medical things you know
where people would say have you been
having trouble with transvaginal mesh
and things like that sort of the only
thing I was hearing people say which a
I'm still baffled about how that is and
hope I never find out anyway are you
having fun so I was love listen to that
and then I would go in the yellow pages
and find you know lawyer's office
caught up and I'd be say I'm having
problems with transvaginal mesh you know
a whole thing like small claims bonus
and if they I thought if I didn't do a
good job they take we were obviously an
English person taking the piss hang up
for me or if they got into a whole
conversation about the thing
then I'd post is that weird no not at
all
I think the sending pictures of your ex
naked that's weird
and I'll sit by that but but no I don't
think it's weird because you were doing
whatever you could to get practice using
yes you see if I get busted with yeah
yeah
you